les etats-unis ont dépensé depuis mars
2020 c'est-à-dire sur un an
grosso modo maintenant sur 13 mois ils
ont dépensé 14 1140 euros par habitant
alors que nous n'avons dépenses et nous
qu'en france que 2500 70 euros les
allemands 4033 l'italie 1737 la belgique
3000 euros donc il y a là aussi une
énorme différence
[Musique]
1400 $ pour chaque américain et ce n'est
peut-être qu'un début
alors qu'aux états unis des millions
employés commencent à recevoir leurs
chèques financé par un plan de relance
massif à 1900 milliards de dollars les
européens eux ne voit toujours rien
venir annonce elle est annoncée l'été
dernier le plan de l'ue à 750 milliards
d'euros n'entrera en vigueur qu'à la fin
de cette année alors l'europe
en fait elle assez pour relancer son
économie n'arrive-t-elle pas trop tard
par rapport aux etats unis c'est l'objet
de l'édito échos ce soir bonsoir jacques
sapir comment expliquez vous cette
différence voir ce fossé entre le plan
de relance américain et son équivalent
européen
bonsoir c'est fanny et bien oui
effectivement c'est une différence qui
est très frappante à et la comparaison
d'une certaine manière elle fait mal
entre le plan que vient de faire voter
joe biden qui est un plan à 1900
milliards de dollars c'est à dire à peu
près 1600 milliards d'euros et le plan
de 750 milliards d'euros qui a été
décidé l'année dernière et qui n'est
toujours pas appliqué par l'union
européenne ajoutons à cela le fait que
évidemment le plan américain n'est pas
le premier n'est pas le seul plan il ya
eu d'autres plans avant qui ont été
faits par donald trump et ça vient
évidemment s'ajouter à toutes ces
différences alors il faut quand même
dire une chose c'est que le plan
européen vient s'ajouter quant à lui à
des différents plans nationaux parce que
les états ont fait une
réponse nationale en partie qu'une
réponse budgétaire national qui n'est
pas négligeable mais néanmoins quand on
regarde l'ensemble défi quand on regarde
le total des chiffres
eh bien oui il y a une très forte
différence entre ce qui sera dépensé aux
états unis et ceux qui sera dépensé dans
les pays de l'union européenne alors
jacquin qui at-il exactement dans ce
plan américain alors ce plan dont de
1900 milliards ou de 1600 milliards
d'euros si on le calcule en euros mais
il comprend plusieurs choses on a tout
d'abord des dezheng des aides qui sont
versées à chaque américain
on a après le paiement d'une allocation
supplémentaire pour les américains qui
sont au chômage
on a ensuite des déductions fiscales
les crédits d'impôts qui sont portés à
3000 $ pour les pour chaque enfant a
entre 6 et 17 ans et pour les enfants en
dessous de 6 ans
ces mêmes 3600 dollars et puis on a
différents autres aides des aides aux
collectivités locales et des aides en
particulier pour la réouverture des
écoles
bon tout ceci fait une masse d'argent
considérables on a dit un ça va faire
1900 milliards de dollars ça c'est quand
même quelque chose qui relève plutôt du
soutien immédiat à l'économie et il faut
dire que les ménages américains
on avait vraiment besoin parce que la
protection sociale aux états unis il
faut toujours s'en souvenir
elle n'est pas du tout au niveau de ce
qui existe en france en allemagne en
belgique en italie ou aux pays bas
donc c'est essentiellement un plan de
soutien de l'économie
comment se situent les états unis par
rapport aux autres grands pays dans le
monde
alors je crois que c'est surtout sur
cette comparaison que l'on va toucher la
différence et je veux dire c'est cette
comparaison là qui nous fait mal quand
on regarde pourquoi et bien parce qu'on
va voir qu'en termes de mesures
budgétaires de contributions budgétaires
au soutien à l'économie les états unis
ils sont quasiment à 26% l'union
européenne est à moins de 5%
la france est autour de 7% l'allemagne
qui est l'un des pays qui a le plus fait
est à 11%
donc on est aujourd'hui confronté à
quelque chose qui est assez étonnant
c'est que ce sont les deux pays qui ont
la réputation d'être les plus libéraux
en est qu'un économie la grande bretagne
et les etats unis qui en ont fait
largement plus en terme de pib si vous
venez en termes de dépenses budgétaires
par rapport au pib que les pays
européens qui ont plutôt la réputation
d'être beaucoup plus sociaux démocrates
ou d'avoir développé un état providence
beaucoup plus fort même la grande
bretagne par exemple elle est au dessus
de 16% et on voit que ça
d'une certaine manière ça ridiculise un
petit peu les chiffres qui sont faits
dans l'union européenne en france en
italie et encore plus en espagne alors
cela veut dire finalement que des états
unis ont été plus touché par la pandémie
que l'union européenne vient non non et
c'est ça qui est aussi extrêmement
étonnant si vous voulez on sait que tous
les pays développés ont connu une
récession de l'ordre de 5% un petit peu
moins de 5%
et là dessus on voit que la récession
aux états unis elle a été relativement
faible comparée à la zone euro
nous avons une rose une récession
globalement en termes de zone euro qui
est plus de deux fois supérieure - 7,2
pour cent contre -3 1% pour les états
unis et en plus en france on est à moins
8,3 en italie on est à moins 9 6%
bon pourquoi est ce que les états unis
ont d'une certaine manière moins
souffert des conséquences économiques de
la pandémie
mais il ya plusieurs raisons à cela la
raison principale étant quand même la
taille du pays et le fait que jamais les
états unis n'ont été globalement fermé
si vous voulez on a eu on a toujours des
situations de confinement dans certains
états sur certaines agglomérations par
exemple nous
orc qui est encore aujourd'hui très
largement confiné mais à côté de ça vous
avez d'autres états où on travaille
normalement
donc cela a quand même beaucoup
contribué à réduire
je dirais le choc économique de la
pandémie jacques on en vient maintenant
aux plans de relance européens dont on
parlait ou est il donc passé
et oui ma soeur stéphanie que voyez-vous
venir
vous connaissez la formule alors il faut
se rappeler une chose ce plan il a été
décidé en juillet 2020 et il a été
ratifié en décembre 2020 on nous annonce
aujourd'hui au mieux qu'il rentrerait en
action cet été c'est à dire avec douze
mois de retard par rapport à la décision
est en réalité on s'attend plutôt à ce
qu'ils rentrent en action à la fin de
l'automne au début de l'hiver donc entre
15 et 18 mois après la décision
alors pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
pris un tel retard alors d'abord il ya
des choses qui sont liées aux procédures
européennes c'est un plan de l'union
européenne
et ça veut donc dire que tous les pays
de l'union européenne doivent voter les
mesures du plan et ça ça va prendre du
temps parce qu'il ya toute une série de
pays qui ont des désaccords et où il va
falloir d'une certaine manière
convaincre les oppositions ça c'est un
premier point deuxième point
eh bien c'est la commission européenne
qui en est responsable parce que la
commission européenne elle demande à
regarder très précisément ce qu'elle va
financer et si ce que les pays ont
décidé de financer ne correspond pas aux
priorités de la commission européenne
elle refuse en tous les cas elle
provoque un mécanisme si vous voulez on
rediscute avec les gouvernements
tout ceci prend du temps et puis il ya
une troisième raison une raison qui peut
être non dit et bien c'est le fait que
il va y avoir des élections à la fin de
l'année en allemagne aura nous avons
tous des élections très importante en
france les élections présidentielles
l'année prochaine
peut-être que le gouvernement français
comme le gouvernement allemand cherche à
retarder l'entrée en action de ce plan
de manière à pouvoir dire si vous voulez
au moment des élections
voilà l'argent européen vient vous voyez
c'est l'union européenne qui nous
protège bon ajoutons à cela une chose
c'est que ces 750 milliards d'euros ils
doivent être dépensés au mieux sur deux
ans et plus de manière plus raisonnable
sur quatre ans donc on n'est pas du tout
au niveau du plan de relance américain
mais les montants de ces plans européens
et américains jacques sont ils
comparables finalement non non
absolument pas alors rappelons l'union
européenne c'est 457 millions
d'habitants pour ces 457 millions
d'habitants nous avons donc 750
milliards d'euros ça nous fait à peu
près 1000 1600 euros par habitant aux
états unis nous avons 1600 milliards
pour 328 millions d'habitants est alors
si on rapporte évidemment à l'ensemble
des mesures de soutien budgétaire
la différence est encore plus en notre
défaveur
les etats-unis ont dépensé depuis mars
2020 c'est-à-dire sur un an grosso modo
maintenant sur 13 mois
ils ont dépensé 14 1140 euros par
habitant alors que nous n'avons dépenses
et nous qu'en france que 2500 70 euros
les allemands 1033 l'italie 1737 la
belgique 3000 euros donc il y a là aussi
une énorme différence alors bien sûr on
dira les pays européens ont plus recouru
à des mesures d'ordre monétaire
mais ces mesures d'ordre monétaire c'est
la banque centrale européenne en réalité
qui les a rendues possibles et puis
qu'est ce qu'elles aboutissent à quoi
aboutit ce tout simplement à accroître
l'endettement l'endettement des
entreprises d'endettement des ménages
c'est pas du tout une bonne solution et
on voit la queue
les etats unis ils ont pris un temps
d'avancé considérable par rapport à ce
que l'on fait en europe
et justement quelles conséquences alors
la conséquence on le voit déjà aux états
unis c'est que l'économie américaine
elle redémarre même si la pandémie est
très loin d'être réglée aux états unis
si vous voulez tout le monde le sait
tout le monde sait qu'il ya toujours
d'énormes problèmes sanitaires bien sûr
les états unis sont aussi très en avance
sur nous sur la vaccination
là non plus il n'y a pas photo comme
comme on dit mais globalement l'économie
redémarre alors ça se voit sur
différents chiffres ça se voit en
particulier sur les dépenses de
construction qui ont littéralement bondi
qui ont explosé d'ailleurs ça pose
aujourd'hui des problèmes en europe et
en france ça fait monter le prix de tous
les matériaux de construction et du bois
pourquoi parce que la demande
aujourd'hui en bois de construction des
états unis est telle qu'elle est en
train de saturer le marché
et puis il ya d'autres chiffres qui sont
extrêmement intéressants et qui montre
que très probablement les états unis ne
revint jamais été ré retrouveront leurs
niveaux de production d'avant la crise
sanitaire vers la fin de cette année
voir la fin de l'automne pour ce qui est
de l'union européenne et en admettant
que la campagne vaccinale se passe comme
prévu ce qui vous le savez est loin
d'être gagné et bien ce serait plutôt à
la fin 2022
donc là encore on voit bien que l'union
européenne a pris un an de retard sur
les etats-unis l'union européenne a pu
dire tout ce qu'elle voulait sur la
mauvaise politique de tram sur la
politique des américains même de joe
biden qui n'étaient pas adéquates face à
la pandémie
la réalité est des lames nous avons pris
un an de retard dans notre réponse face
à la crise
et ça ça va jouer parce qu'on voit bien
que l'europe elle est en train de
décrocher
ld
croches et ça je vous l'avais déjà dit
par rapport à la chine et à l'asie du
sud-est c'était évident mais ce qui est
nouveau aujourd'hui
est ce que l'on voit de plus en plus
dans les chiffres économiques c'est
qu'elle décroche aussi très nettement
par rapport aux états unis alors jacques
que faudrait-il faire bien ce que l'on
voit c'est que aujourd'hui il faut d'une
certaine manière de la flexibilité il
faut peut-être mettre de côté ce cadre
de l'union européenne qui par sa
bureaucratie par les compromis qui sont
nécessaires au sein des 27 pays qui nous
tire en arrière qui est en train de
plomber littéralement l'économie
l'économie de la france mais aussi
globalement l'économie des pays de
l'union européenne il est temps et ça je
pense que c'est quelque chose dont on
est tous en train de prendre conscience
et qui jouera évidemment un rôle
extrêmement important lors de la
prochaine élection présidentielle
il est temps de renationaliser nos
politiques économiques
on voit bien que l'union européenne
n'est pas capable de faire ce pour quoi
elle a été créée